I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance late in the afternoon of
Tuesday the 22nd of November I signed
onto my email account was startled to
see a red banner at the top of the
screen reading government backed
attackers maybe trying to steal your
password I had my doubts and then came a
tweet from Paul Krugman of the New York
Times while he was in the middle of a
tweet storm about the possibility of a
hacked election Krugman wrote that he
had received the same warning then a
writer at Politico said she had gotten
one as well and then Ezra Klein and an
author in Turkey and an amnesty
international expert on China and
somebody at the center for
nonproliferation studies and a human
rights advocate in Egypt and a project
headed King's College London and a
student political activist in Hong Kong
then about two dozen journalists and
opposition leaders in Russia and Michael
McFaul
a former US ambassador to Russia all in
about 12 hours there's a chance this is
a false alarm but we believe we detected
government-backed attackers trying to
steal your password this happens to less
than 0.1 percent of all Gmail users we
can't reveal what tipped us off because
the attackers will take note and change
their tactics but if they are successful
at some point they could access your
data or take other actions using your
account G government backed attackers
I wonder which government it is one
thing to read that your country's
intelligence services believe that
government backed attackers breached the
email systems of the Democratic Party or
that government backed attackers tried
to influence the outcome of the
presidential election or that government
backed attackers tried to access the
voter registration rolls of at least 20
states it is one thing to hear one
candidate who wound up being elected by
a minority of voters flippantly dismiss
the evidence that those government
backed attackers were identified and yet
also called for the same country to hack
the email of his opponent it is one
thing to read a story suggesting that
government backed attackers help spread
the so called fake news that clearly
influenced our educationally challenged
voters
clearly influences still our
psychologically challenged
president-elect but let me assure you it
is quite another thing to see the red
stripe across the screen of your laptop
put there as warning by people who are
anything but amateurs in this field
suggesting that those government backed
attackers are now targeting you it's
like a decade ago when I was sent fake
anthrax three times the envelopes were
disturbing the Gaul the perpetrator was
infuriating but it only became
frightening indeed it only became real
when the FBI showed up and took it
seriously enough to quarantine the
building and stick me into a hazmat suit
extra-large it's like the quote from the
father of the dictionary Samuel Johnson
depend upon it sir when a man knows he
is to be hanged in a fortnight it
concentrates his mind wonderfully I no
longer have to have proved to be line by
line the claim that government backed
attackers facilitated the spreading of
preposterous Internet stories to sway
the vote I no longer need to know the
precise motives of the NSA director and
would-be Trump administration
apparatchik Michael Rogers went eight
days after the election he said if
WikiLeaks and the publishing of the DNC
emails quote there shouldn't be any
doubt in anybody's minds this was not
something that was done casually this
was not something that was done by
chance this was not a target that was
selected purely arbitrarily this was a
conscious effort by a nation-state to
attempt to achieve a specific effect I
no longer need to have diagram for me
the actions of former Trump campaign
manager Paul metaphors and foreign
policy advisor Carter page and Vladimir
Putin and Donald Trump I no longer need
to know who the Russian oligarchs are to
whom Rudy Giuliani's company has on the
record provided quote image consulting I
no longer need to know why Trump has
reportedly begged off his ultra secret
intelligence briefings and I don't need
to know if his fawning SiC of fancy
towards Putin is the result of mere
manipulation or part of Trump's mental
illness all I need to know is someone
approach this so thoroughly with
an unnecessarily broad net that they
even tried to hack my email that vague
feeling that the idea of massive
computer hacking and propaganda
spreading could not really have happened
because honestly you can't really
picture it in your mind how it would
have happened that protective layer
healthy skepticism that is gone this is
all real it has all occurred and whether
Donald Trump knew about it or he did not
whether he can understand it or he is
too far gone mentally to appreciate it
it has been accomplished the Russians
got who they wanted to run the United
States of America for them as surely as
if we were East Germany to their Soviet
Union in 1950 or as surely as if they
had invaded us and placed their own
feeble-minded manipulated by flattery
satellite dictator in the White House
and in seven weeks we will inaugurate a
new president who was not our choice
but their's resist peace